devant le palais de la source du
département de la réunion des jeunes et
des moins jeunes se sont retrouvés ces
visages connus des anciennes générations
sont aujourd'hui observée par les jeunes
représentants des collèges réunionnais
des personnes importantes du département
des historiens des députés certains je
ne sais pas de bêtises
monsieur le président que la viande soit
arrivé aussi donc voilà d'intervenants
qui pourront nous aider et répondre à
nos questions au sujet de la
départementalisation pour être actif va
intervenir
on va en apprendre plus sur le passé
pour pouvoir faire plus pour l'avenir et
c'est ça le but on colle à venir ce qui
met l'avenir c'est nous mais c'est en
vrai c'est aussi eux parce que si nous
aide pas bon
on n'ira pas loin
depuis 75 ans ce lieux rassemblent ce
lieu partage ce lieu permet la
transmission entre générations
pour cela chacun dans son domaine
d'activité a pu parler avec son coeur
[Musique]
puis ensemble
fectivement le vivre ensemble le
consensus social fait particulier
ensemble
et l'aménagement c'est un élément de
consensus social que ça marche et c'est
surtout un élément de faire ensemble au
delà du vivre ensemble n'ont pas besoin
d'aller des grandes écoles faire débat
pucelle et plus 10 cl pragmatique savoir
ce qu'on a envie avoir cette capacité à
lancer le rattrapage depuis 1946 a été
énorme la santé a emmené le progrès des
projets d'envergure ont suivi dans le
domaine des transports de l'éducation de
l'agriculture de la culture ou encore du
sport
et j'espère que l'offre
alimentaire vient s'ajouter au fait que
quand même dire l'annoncé
quant aux chances d'accrocher des
septuagénaires et des collégiens pour
faire ensemble société voilà le fil
conducteur de cette matinée nous avons
décidé en quelque sorte aujourd'hui de
donner le coup d'envoi des
manifestations qui vont jalonner d'année
2021 symboliquement ce que on a voulu
faire des maîtres dans un dialogue
fécond nourrit mettre ensemble réunir
des gens qui ont construit la réunion
nos aînés qu'on pourrait qualifier de
d'enfants de la départementalisation
devenu aujourd'hui adultes
et puis les jeunes de la
décentralisation qui montrent d'une part
la gratitude que nous devons avoir
l'égard de ses anciens toujours bonne
forme physique intellectuel est
également la préparation de l'avenir
avec nos jeunes du cdj et qui était
soigné ce matin c'est notre vivant
ensemble vivre ensemble constitue le
socle aujourd'hui de cette population
réunionnaise beaucoup d'informations
sont passés ce jour là c'est maintenant
à chacun de nous de s'approprier le
passé afin de construire l'avenir
ensemble
[Musique]